so David I'm so inspired by what you all
accomplished in Connecticut I want to do
the same thing Nationwide so check it
out here's how we do it nationwide the
2020 presidential race was decided by
about 70 000 voters in four states uh
and they're going to be about six swing
States in 2024 we know what they are
it's Arizona Nevada Wisconsin Georgia
are the four core swing States and then
you could throw in Michigan and
Pennsylvania so let's go get four
percent of the voters the independent
swing voters in those six swing States
just to raise their hands and say hey we
will support whichever major Party
candidate supports non-partisan
primaries and ranked Choice voting and
gets out of the way of the ballot
initiatives it'll probably be on the
ballot in 2024 in Nevada and maybe
Arizona and a couple of other states I
love it I love it absolutely it's a
perfect place to put the energy of the
independent movement and and you touched
on a couple themes there first is the
incentive structure you know I actually
I think tone is important in the
independent movement you have a lot of
people who are just angry and they're
always going to be angry and they're
going to beat up on the on the parties I
don't know that that helps us a lot
because the reality is
candidates today and incumbents are
responding to the incentive structure
that lets them keep their job and we all
do that in every Walk of Life if if
you're a street sweeper or a doctor you
do the things that let you keep your job
and get ahead and so we can beat up
incumbent Republicans and democrats for
their behavior but it's not going to
change anything because they're acting
rationally within the system if we can
change the system we will change their
behavior you articulate this perfectly
well Andrew when you're out across the
country if we change the incentives we
change their behavior and and that's
where the independent space is
contributing so much to the politics of
the country it the independent space
likes to get kicked around and oh these
rabble rousers are doing bad things no
no no look if the independent space
changes the incentive structure in the
country then one of the two major
parties is going to realize wait a
minute if we broaden our tent if we
reach for more consensus and we can get
rewarded for it I've said this to my
Democratic friends you would have a
governing Coalition for the next three
decades you would be a 60 party not a 51
or 52 percent party and within the
independent space there are reasons to
say we need a multi-party democracy it
is all over the world we are the outlier
and not having it all of the metrics all
the studies say multi-party democracy is
more effective but in the screwed up way
we do politics in America if the
contribution of multi-party Advocates is
to actually create a bigger tent within
one of the major parties that says wait
we want to represent more and more of
America that's a heck of a contribution
and something to be proud of
[Music]
foreign